what i wasn't quite prepared for was
the ways that we were gonna kind of big
sister
our younger selves and each other you
know we've been able to talk about all
the things
that we were too scared to bring up back
then and we've really been able to kind
of
come to each other's rescue and defense
and we just laugh a lot and the coolest
part is that
we're finally seeing our show the way
our audience
saw it we'd never done that as a fan in
a way
yeah i you know even if we'd catch an
episode to live tweet or something
we would have just made it it was like
everything was jumbly right
now we are just seeing the episodes
and it's wild and the number of times
we'll all get choked up and we're like
oh man it really hits it hits it's a
really good show
really that's amazing it's really sweet
well you talk about all the stuff that
you guys went through and i know you've
talked about it
a lot i mean and you paint the picture
of that
this guy was the creator of the show was
basically a monster
yeah i mean there's no secret to that no
it's amazing to me how he could be is so
open usually you think
that it'd be one or two people that
experience it
but how many people experienced this uh
18 women
on our show signed a collective letter
and that was 18 people willing to be
public about their experiences in the
cast and on the crew
and 25 women on the cast and crew of his
subsequent show signed
a letter in response about his behavior
and it was obvious in front of the crew
oh yeah he was very open i think the
worst of what he did was hidden
um but yeah he
he was not embarrassed to be handsy to
make inappropriate commentary he just
thought he can get away with it
to pull people into side rooms for
conversations um
to keep it's funny when you think about
the things that men write
you know we would have these scenes
written for us
you know being with our intimate
partners on the show scenes written
where we'd be in our underwear and
whatever
and we found out from a writer that he
kept a board
of the fitting photos of each girl
in underwear up in his office pictures
of us that were taken by the wardrobe
supervisor who was a woman
of us in different versions of underwear
and or lingerie that
that then had to be approved picked and
you know that one would wind up in the
show
he just would keep a board of all these
photos
and we were like wow that's super
violating did anybody ever say
get help dude get [ __ ] help uh yeah
certainly but when someone's in complete
and total control
of 250 people's jobs and livelihoods
it's pretty hard to force them to listen
but it was interesting for us you know
when the show was over
uh really to hear that it was no secret
in the industry either and he kept
working as they all do
until you know this all came out the
movement
and then he was fired off royals or
whatever did you ever do
how do you feel if you ever were face to
face with him in a room
just the two of you to have a
conversation
do you think you could keep your
composure i could do a conversation like
this
you could but even as you asked me to
imagine it like the
sensation of white hot rage in my chest
is not
small because not only was it the really
overt
just abuse and manipulation that he
you know put so many women through but
it was also
the more insidious [ __ ] it was
telling me that joy and hillary were
supposedly talking all this [ __ ] about
me
and then telling joy that me and hillary
were talking [ __ ] about her
and telling hillary that me and joy were
talking [ __ ] about her
he he all hate each other he pitted us
against each other
and when you're 21 and your 45 year old
married boss
is telling you that people are coming
into his office to talk about you
you don't think he's making it up and so
the ferocity that i
feel about the time he stole from us
because we clicked fast and we were
really really close
and he didn't like it and it took us a
long time to realize that
you know when he would talk about never
letting us be like the friends cast
we always thought like yeah lol like
what cast is ever going to get paid that
much money an episode
yeah but what we didn't realize was that
he never wanted us to be
best friends because then we would talk
about money and then we would advocate
together
it wouldn't be that kind of money but
joined forces we would join forces and
we didn't
get that at the time we were kids we
didn't know anything about the business
this was my first tv show